[music playing]
MAN 1: Does it feel different
to be up there without a rope?
MAN 2: It's obviously like
much higher consequence.
MAN 3: People who know a little
bit about climbing, they're
like, oh, he's totally safe.
And then people who really
know exactly what he's doing
are freaked out.
MAN 2: I've thought about
El Cap like for years.
And every year I'm like,
that's really scary.
I'll never be content unless
I at least put in the effort.
El Cap is the most
impressive wall on Earth.
It's 3,200 feet
of sheer granite.
It's the center of the
rock climbing universe.
Obviously I get interview
questions about it
all the time.
Oh, would you like to do that?
You're like, yes, for sure.
[music playing]
MAN 4: So you got a
girlfriend now I heard.
MAN 2: It's awesome, pretty much
makes life better in every way.
WOMAN 1: It's really hard for
me to grasp why he wants this.
But and if he doesn't do
this stuff, he'd regret it.
MAN 5: Everybody who has
made free soloing a big part
of their life is dead now.
MAN 2: I haven't been
injured in like seven years.
I suddenly start getting
injured all the time.
WOMAN 1: What if
something happens?
Aah!
WOMAN 1: What if I
don't see him again?
MAN 2: I could just walk away.
But it's like, I don't want to.
MAN 6: I've always
been conflicted
about shooting a film
about free soloing
just because it's so dangerous.
It's hard to not imagine
your friend falling
through the frame to his death.
WOMAN 2: I think when
he's free soloing
that's when he feels the
most alive, most everything.
How can you even think about
taking that away from somebody?
MAN 2: No mistakes tomorrow.
I'm starting to become afraid.
If you're pushing the edge,
eventually you find the edge.
MAN 7: I can't believe you guys
are actually going to watch.
Hey, Jimmy, do you copy?
Just started climbing.
[breathing heavily]
[music playing]